herzlich willkommen ja vor 200 jahren
wurde gottfried keller geboren der
berühmte schweizer schriftsteller dessen
romane und novellen sie sich ja noch aus
der schulzeit kennen etwa der grüne
heinrich kleider machen leute oder romeo
und julia auf dem dorfe
in der folgenden stunde will ich
erfahren was uns gottfried keller heute
noch zu sagen hat und mein heutiger gast
meint ganz schön viel
philipp theisohn gilt als shootingstar
der literaturwissenschaft und übernimmt
diesen sommer die professur für neuere
deutsche literatur an der universität in
zürich herzlich willkommen
gottfried keller gilt als einer der ganz
großen warum eigentlich
also wenn man mit einem ganz großen ein
autor bezeichnet der für uns noch
relevanz hat also dem wir noch lesen
obwohl er schon 200 jahre alt ist dann
kann man sagen er hat weil abbas hat was
andere autoren eben nicht haben also
sein sein werk beinhaltet etwas das wir
bei anderen autoren nicht finden und
dass wir offensichtlich für relevant
halten für uns und wird mir nicht mehr
lesen und was wäre hätte also kelle ist
eigentlich der so was wie der autor der
würdigen enttäuschung
das heißt es ist ein auto der texte
schreibt die sich immer wieder an
figuren und ein lebensläufen abarbeiten
die auch so der selbsttäuschung beruhen
also figuren die sehr hohes also sich
selbst ein
also figuren die einen falsches
selbstbild mit sich umhertragen die sich
über höhen und die dann lernen müssen
dass sie dann doch nicht das sind was
sie eigentlich sein soll also die lernen
scheitern könnte man sagen werden durch
diese texte auch gebrochen aber nie so
dass sie dann entwürdigt werden dabei
sondern sie lernen dabei eigentlich wie
man auch ohne größte fantasie eine würde
erlangen kann der text oder die texte
lassen ihnen diese würde
und am schluss sind sie wie das zum
beispiel in die dicken heißt das ist
eine novelle aus dem sind wieder ein
zyklus nicht am schluss heißt das was
ist das ist die dicken in kriege und
dann heißt es nicht besser als andere
jeder zeiten viel mehr vielmehr die mit
den gleichen fehler nicht durch die
gleichen fehler eigentlich geprägt und
dieses fehler haben nicht und bei den
fehlern bleiben dann wird die auch
eigentlich nicht los aber muss sie halt
erkennen das ist eigentlich das wenige
was sie bei keller immer wieder finden
und auch lernen können über dieses über
dieses motiv des scheiterns des
misslingens dieser überhöhten erwartet
wie die aber das werden wir sprechen
jetzt interessiert mich aber am anfang
noch wie aktuell ist denn das werk warum
sonja keller gerade heute lesen ist weil
genau dieses moment des scheiterns genau
diese momente scheiterns in würde etwas
ist was wir eigentlich verlernt haben
und wir müssen das ganz leicht oben und
sagen es geht darum so was wie erkenne
dich selbst stehe zu seinen schwächen
also solche solche selbsthilfe beratungs
monologe die es da gibt aber das macht
keller gerade nicht sondern was keller
macht ist ersetzt eigentlich diese ja
man könnte sagen erzählungen des
scheiterns im sozialen kontext in
gesellschaftliche kontext
das heißt er zeigt was passiert
eigentlich eine gesellschaft in der ganz
viele von diesen individuen herumlaufen
die in falsches selbstbild mit sich
tragen und permanent darauf gestoßen
werden dass sie eigentlich gar nicht das
sind
was sie sein sollen oder sein wollen
wenn ohne was ich zu sagen glauben oder
was jetzt sagen glauben und was passiert
mit mit so einer gesellschaft in der so
viele individuen
dieses problem haben das nicht
einzusehen und mit dem scheitern nicht
zurechtkommen diese leute projizieren
die schuld an der diskrepanz zwischen
dem selbstbild und der realität nach
außen also jemand muss dafür
verantwortlich sein dass ich noch nicht
oder nicht mehr oder gar nicht das bin
was ich einig sein soll
und da kann keller tatsächlich sehr gut
analysieren wie in der gesellschaft
polarisierungen polemik hass auf kommt
die sich die leute auch misstrauen wie
es zu solchen phänomenen wie mobbing
kommt nicht wenn man mir eine novelle
ließ wie das verlorene lachen da geht es
genau um so was also die entsteht das
eigentlich warum fachleute an andere
auszuschließen zu diffamieren wie es
heißt zu entstellen weil das alles
effekte sind von ja eine nicht
bewältigen enttäuschung
die man mit sich herumträgt den anderen
die schuld geben man kennt das heute in
szeged all das keine sehr gut wie
gerüchte in umwelt um rp gerücht in
umlauf gebracht werden das kann man bei
canon sehr gut sehen wie das
funktioniert
man braucht ja gar nicht mal und dass
das nennt man eigentlich jetzt erst über
soziale medien wie so etwas funktioniert
aber keller hat doch schon vorher
gekannt
man braucht nicht nur einen ganz
konkreten vorwurf reicht wenn man sagt
irgendwas stimmt da nicht und der kennt
wiederum jemanden der denjenigen kennt
und der denjenigen kennen und wir sind
irgendwie hängen die zusammen schon hat
man im grunde eine gruppe isoliert und
die sind in ihrer sprechpausen gelähmt
dadurch und das kann man da lernen bei
kinder schon sehr früh ich habe sie der
anmoderation gesagt 200 jahre feiern wir
geburtstag
gottfried keller am 19 juli 18 19
geboren derzeit wieder wird er überall
gelobt es gibt ausstellungen kongresse
und so weiter man betont immer wieder
wie gut und wichtig der war geht es nach
dinge die er so richtig schlecht gemacht
hat peinliche passage die man heute
besser wissen sollte über lesen soll man
sowieso gar nichts weil man es kann sein
dass wir heute ganz viele sachen grausig
finden die man in 50 jahren ganz toll
findet wenn man einfach das anders sehen
kann
also was ich sagen würde ist dass seine
lyrik aus meiner perspektive nicht so
groß ist wie er sie gesehen hat das hat
er mit anderen realisten also mit
sterben zum beispiel gemein dass sie
alle gelacht haben wissen doch lyriker
und man kennt die rag heute eigentlich
gar nicht so richtig mehr gut und keller
ist schon in der ethik breiter auch
übrigens auch gestorben jemand der
eigentlich gern dramatik auch geworden
wäre uns nie wurde
man kann sagen das konnte er nicht gut
also als lyriker listen gescheiter als
dramatiker als maler werden als jähriger
gescheitert hätte er nie gesagt aber ich
würde sagen in der qualität ist dann
doch bis auf wenige spitzen
die prosa schon schon dasjenige was
einigen vordergrund stehen sollte bei
keller
derzeit läuft eine ausstellung im museum
strauhof in zürich und zug eller der
träumende realist heißt die und da gibt
es auch stellungnahmen von expertinnen
und experten einen schriftsteller und
literaturwissenschaftler und wir hören
uns mal 23 stimmen dazu machen er ist
ein funkelnder erzähler ein zähler von
einem witzen deinem humor der fast
unheimlich abgründiges gleichzeitig ein
großer genießer ein mann der festlichen
momente und dahinter ist immer eine
tiefe schwermut eine verschattung ein
abgrund auch der trauer die überhaupt
nie ganz sich auflöst und diese spannung
ist für ihn ganz bezeichnen
das eine schärfung verstärkt das andere
die festlichkeit ist nur möglich wegen
den tiefen schwermut tagen wochen
monaten das geht bei ihm auf monate und
das löst sich dann wieder auf in einer
unvergleichlich farbiger und funk und in
prosa gottfried keller hat einen ganz
ganz besonderen für mich sogar
einzigartigen sinn für das große zum
beispiel für bäume für den wald und ganz
besonders für die natur aber eigentlich
auch für das göttliche
obwohl er es dann in der zweiten hälfte
seines lebens nicht mehr im himmel oder
in einer metaphysischen dimension findet
sondern in der welt drin
aber er hat auch einen ganz besonderen
sinn für das kleine das winzige auch das
kleinliche und ich glaube es ist kein
zufall dass er das kleine und kleinliche
vor allem in der menschenwelt findet
also eine lieblingsfigur die ich
gefunden habe ist schon babys oder hieß
eben erst johannes johannes rabbis
wahrscheinlich und das kling klang ihm
aber zu wenig weltoffen oder wichtig
auch und um sein glück zu finden hat er
sich dann in jon peace umbenannt und
wollte dann zusätzlich auch noch weil
das irgendwie auch nicht funktioniert
das glück dann trotzdem nicht gekommen
ist wollte er noch eine frau heiraten
die er gefunden hat im dorf die olive
oli frollein oliva hieß und dann hat er
gedacht dann könne er schon babys oliva
heißen und wenn dann das glück nicht
kommt dann wird er irgendwie das ist ja
unmöglich
und dann hat herausgefunden dass sie nur
ihre mutter so heißt und sie selbst aber
köpfe genau und dann hätte er john cages
köpfle geheißen und das war dann nicht
das was er sich vorgestellt hat und da
dann aber die mutter gefragt ob sie ihn
vielleicht heiraten würde
und sie wollte dann nicht das ist
und um sie zu fragen ob sie ihn heiraten
will hat er sich alle wertsachen die er
besitzt irgendwie an sich dran gehängt
also nein so etwas rührendes ja was sich
durch zieht ist dieser kontrast zwischen
dem ganz großen und ihnen ganz kleinen
oder zwischen dem dunklen abgründigen
und zwischen den hellen und humorvollen
festlichen die passenden diese beiden
gegensätzlichen stimmungswerte zusammen
also muss ein bisschen trend also die
sache mit der kleinheit ist ist eine
sache die wichtig ist sicher wenn man
jetzt zunächst mal fragt worin liegen
eigentlich diese also was macht in
dieser spannung aus zwischen diesen test
die strahlenden und dem und dem auf
vernichteten ja dann könnte man wenn man
den grünen heinrich denkt zum beispiel
nicht der grüne heinrich kommt zurück in
die schweiz 18 44 geht über basel kommt
an das große eidgenössische schützenfest
gleichzeitig 400 jahr feier der schlacht
von sankt jakob man sieht den großen
aufzogen denkt dass es so wie es
geschildert wird nicht da entsteht jetzt
war es nicht die die eidgenossenschaft
ist schon auf dem vormarsch sie kommt
die stimmung ist entsprechend
ist ganz pathetisch und das nicht nur
dem heinrich gar nichts weil als der
eigentlich nach hause kommt erwartet
daraufhin keinen festzug sondern in der
beerdigungszug seiner mutter und er
selbst stirbt dann auch später nicht
also der bruch ist eigentlich mit
inbegriffen bei das heißt natürlich dass
es dann frei nach walter benjamin
hoffnung gibt es halt dann schon aber
für uns eben nicht
ja also wir für uns gibt es die hoffnung
nicht und das ist bei keller immer mit
dabei nicht dass er eigentlich sagt es
geht nicht dass es gar keine hoffnung
gibt oder alles ist schlecht sondern die
misere das individuums das modernen
individuums liegt darin dass sie sehen
kann was möglich wäre aber der einzelne
ist nicht mehr erreichen kann und das
ist eigentlich der bruch der sowohl das
werk als auch das leben von keller ein
bisschen durchzieht kenia aber dieses
dieses diese verschattung dieses
abgedunkelt das läuft immer mit wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe selbst in den
festlichen heiteren humorvollen
geschichte das gibt es überall also
selbst eine erzählung wie einem die drei
gerechten kammacher die eigentlich
sicher eine von den lustigsten
erzählungen ist ja geändert damit dass
der eine
er kriegt die cs bünzli der kommt dann
noch einigermaßen gut weg muss halt aber
unter ihr leiden
der zweite erhängt sich der dritte wird
wahnsinnig das ist keine weitere
erzählungen wenn wir nach dem ende gehen
aber es ist noch ein bisschen zu dem
punkt kommt denkt man das ist ja
wahnsinnig was das für figuren sind was
alkotester szenerien man da die ganze
zeit hat und dann kommt das ende und das
schwingt immer mit und gibt dass es gibt
eigentlich muss müsste lange überlegen
wie sich eine kelle erzählung finde wo
ich sagen würde
da hat das dann eben nicht dass es gibt
immer dies interessant ist
wir haben schon über dieses scheitern
gesperrten das irgendwie zentrale ist
die theorie kreisen um das warum denn
ist das so zentral und hat das mit
seiner eigenen biografie auch zu tun
also wenn man das nicht ganz platt
machen und sagen da hat der rat aber von
sehr viel misserfolg geplagt und hat
deswegen laute erfolglose figuren
entworfen
aber natürlich ist es so dass es einen
tag das im grunde sind es scheitern zwar
das aus einem scheitern heraus auch
entstanden ist würde ich sagen ich hatte
grüne heinrich der erste gesetzte romand
ist ja teilweise hat nokia hat seine
prognose schreckt und hat seine jugend
geschichte da verarbeitet und also man
kann sagen wenn man sich kellers
biografie anschaut ja
amourös gescheitert und zwar ein leben
lang immer wieder gescheitert also
wieder verliebt ihr mehrere länder
wieder unglücklich verliebt schulische
karriere von der schule geflogen
ja auf erfolg erfolglos erst nach 14 5
jahren erste berufliche ausbildung im
grunde in sand gesetzt dabei
landschaftsmaler werden wobei ich ihn
gar nicht so schlecht finde wie er sich
gefunden hat oder wie andere ihn
gefunden haben ich finde es eigentlich
ganz okay aber jedenfalls nicht
realisiert und das ist irgendwie ja die
vorgeschichte dass das was uns der grüne
heinrich im grunde bis dahin man kann
sagen
während der grüne heinrich an diesem
permanent scheitern zu grunde geht es
gottfried keller derjenige der aus
dieser geschichte dieses scheiterns am
woche durch ein spurwechsel nämlich von
der malerei in die literatur ein werk
das scheitern schafft und so eine zweite
karriere einig beginnt die dann eben
nicht scheitert sondern die 1
daneben dann doch einen erfolg münchen
den er das scheitern zum thema macht
gerne aussagen auch sein eigenes
scheitern im grunde weiterführte sie
haben gottfried keller auch den anbau
des in perfekter nicht genannt in
vorgesprächen ich fand das interessant
das heißt dass wir eigentlich immer
dieses ideale selbstbild haben oder
gefahr laufen zu hohe sieht ja alles
selbst wird zu haben jetzt in unserer
heutigen zeit wo wir von
selbstoptimierung reden dass das
zauberwort der stunde zeigt uns da
keller eigentlich dass wir mit dieser
idee von selbstoptimierung auf dem
holzweg sind also das problem ist
natürlich dass man wenn man über
selbstoptimierung spricht dass eine
andere richtung ausschlagen kann und
kenne sich auch nichts dagegen gehabt
hätte der man sagen muss schon
ambitionen haben besser zu werden nicht
weil ein teil des scheiterns besteht
immer darin dass man sagt okay jetzt
habe ich meine fehler gesehen jetzt muss
ich anders machen nicht also selbst doch
die einsicht dass man vieles nicht kann
könnte ein weg in gesetzt optimierung
sein was bei keller aber zweifellos
nicht da es ist dass man sagt es geht
hier um so diese vorstellung auf unserem
bildungsroman nicht also man muss erst
dreimal auf die herdplatte lang und da
macht man es nicht mehr und dann wird
man jemand der nächsten mal handschuhe
an hat das heißt im scheitern schon
gleich vorweg nehmen dass man über das
scheitern aus also jedes scheitern eine
chance ist das hat man bei keller
eigentlich gar nicht sondern es kann
auch einfach sein dass man im scheitern
dabei stehen bleibt zu sagen ich bin
nicht mehr als die anderen ich hab' ich
muss einfach damit zurechtkommt ich muss
mich letztendlich in der unmöglichkeit
von größe zum beispiel einrichten
das ist unglaublich ein großer
unterschied also selbst perfektion heißt
natürlich immer mit einer vorstellung um
laufen
es gibt so was wie eine unbesiegbarkeit
die man irgendwie erreichen kann es gibt
es gibt eben so ein endstadium nicht in
bestimmten bereichen wo man dann auch
sich gar nicht verbessern kann oder an
dem man sich messen muss und keller hat
ihre kellers texte kommen immer wieder
eigentlich auf den punkt dass man die
die figuren richten sich tatsächlich in
diese unmöglichkeit von größe 1 oder das
beschneiden und leben da ist
bescheidenheit wer die tugend
bescheidung und bescheidenheit ist das
problem sobald ihr jetzt bescheidenheit
sagen ist das schon wieder ne tun indem
man sich wieder verbessern kann und so
so her ist das gar nicht bei keller
sondern das ist einfach so wie es vorhin
sagt nicht auch wie alle anderen den
fehlern der zeit unterworfen ja darüber
raus geht's halt einfach nicht und das
einzusehen und sagen gut und dann macht
man mal sowas aus den resten was wir
noch haben das natürlich da kommen dann
auf die poetik und auf die kleinheit
aber heißt das jetzt man kann keine
großen träume haben gesagt ambitionen
schon noch doch man kann die schon haben
nur wenn man in kellersberg unterwegs
ist da merkt man diese figuren erreichen
diese träume meistens auf den wegen
nicht das glück erreichen sie so nicht
weil die großen träume meistens nicht
sozial gedacht werden können
meistens nicht in gesellschaft gedacht
werden können das teilte damit ganz
vielen ja utopischen fantasien utopien
sind meistens einig dass kopien von dem
er die gesellschaft abgezogen hat byebye
keller ist es tatsächlich so dass man
diese großen träume ein ich nicht leben
kann nicht die leute die große träume
die in großen träumen leben das sind die
wahnsinnigen also zum beispiel der kurz
vorm walde aus dem missbrauchten die das
briefen der meint der berliner der
größten dichter der gegenwart und wir
mal von außen drauf guckt ist es halt
jemand also man sagen würde macht
irgendwas vernünftiges mit deinem leben
jetzt aber nicht das ja er macht aber
immer wieder und deswegen finden wir das
lustig lebt in seiner eigenen traumwelt
ja ja aber er findet ja sogar noch eine
partnerin die das auch so sieht
ich meine neben diesen
gesellschaftlichen ideal von heute der
selbstoptimierung gibt es ja das ideal
der selbstverwirklichung werden selbst
authentizität war das denn für keller er
einige jahre dass er unterschreiben und
oder ein ziel auf das hinzuarbeiten sich
lohnen wenn es nicht selbst zu sein
also es ja also keller würde das
wahrscheinlich eher negativ formulieren
nicht also so schwierig ist ein
schwierig ist ganz euphorisch und
affirmativ ein echtes leben zu führen
wie wie der busfahrer also danach auf
manneck der quasi meint erwähnter
falschen zeit und ein echtes leben hat
dass die schwierigkeit bei dem begriff
authentizität auch jenseits von keller
liegt natürlich darin dass die
vorstellung authentisch zu sein
also man kann ja mal ausprobieren zu
sagen ich bin jetzt authentisch und der
ist mir schon nicht mehr weil
authentisch zu sein ja eigentlich
bedeutet es gibt einen punkt an dem man
ganz präsent ist ganz substanz ist ohne
zeichen ist keine rolle spielen
[Musik]
und das ist was bei dem ich sagen würde
da fährt kellers prosa mal ganz heftig
dazwischen weil sogar die leute die
gerade dabei sind zu sagen ich habe mich
geläutert an kratzte schmoller der sagt
ich bin jetzt nach 15 jahren schmollen
den kartoffelbrei bin ich durch die
ganze welt und habe dabei durch eine
frau und eine begegnung mit einem löwen
gelernt nicht mehr zu schmollen und
jetzt erzähle ich euch die geschichte
jetzt komme ich zu mir selber also diese
überhöhung gespannt habe ich abgelegt
und dahinter das erzählt schlafen die
beiden zu hören sein
schlafen einkriegen die entscheidende
geschichte nicht mit die
liebesgeschichte und dann geht es darum
jetzt waren wir das nicht mitgekriegt
wie ich erzählt aber nicht nur ich sage
weder beleidigend schon wieder erweitert
er wird diese fehler gar nicht los und
das heißt es wird der mensch kann
eigentlich nicht authentisch sind wir
spielen immerhin rollen
das zu wissen ist gut ich meine es gibt
ja dieses berühmte stücken die leute von
selbst wieder kleider machen leute
ja ja ja und da kommt das ja auch dass
wir irgendwie durch die inszenierung von
uns selbst irgendwie an selbst weg
gewinnen auch ich bestimmte dinge
erreichen können in der welt in der
gesellschaft und und da gibt es eine
andere geschichte wo jemand die hat die
junge hat das erwähnten namen ja der
schmidt seines glückes sehr genau das
heißt so dieses rollenspiel die
selbstinszenierung permanent auch ein
thema beim verkehr ist kann man ein
thema als mein kleider machen leute ist
deswegen natürlich vor allem interessant
weil man ja merkt der wenzel strawinsky
das ist ja jemand der bekommt der
inszeniert sich selbst und der wird
inszeniert nicht so durch bemerkungen
durch das etwas über zieht aber er macht
das ja eigentlich ursprünglich gar nicht
in der absicht jemanden zu täuschen
er nimmt dann rolle an die ihm
angetragen wird und das machen wir ja
natürlich auch sehr häufig oder ist die
rolle erst mal von anderen geschrieben
der jahr hier nehmen sie haben also die
art wie man an moderiert wird die art
wie man irgendwo fremde die man heute
sagen also wenn es nicht negativ ist
nimmt man das erstmal mit und schon
man auch einmal kompetenzen die man gar
nicht hat und titel die man gar nicht
hat wobei das hat man eigentlich selten
sie geben mir das stichwort ich habe sie
als shootingstar der
literaturwissenschaftler an moderiert ja
sobald ich ohne gelohnt
sie sind ja wirklich ein hansdampf für
den augen lassen kann man sagen ich muss
es auch lesen was sie ausgemacht haben
sie haben germanistik mediävistik
philosophie studiert in gehwegen und
zürich wurden dann 2013 förder
professoren in zürich haben wirklich
keine scheu vortags und popkultur also
sie hier hatten ein forschungsprojekt
geleitet zum außerirdischen leben ja in
der literatur haben ein buch über das
plagiat geschrieben beraten die
kulturstiftung pro helvetia schreiben
rezensionen sind mitherausgeber einer
renommierten zeitschrift betreiben ein
literatur blogs sind präsidenten theodor
storm gesellschaft baut ordentlicher
professor und sie sprechen als
gebürtiger deutscher eigentlich perfekt
schweizerdeutsch als kämen sie von
fribourg aber sie hier gleich in zürich
wie machen sie das alles wie bringen sie
das unter einen hut und ist da die
gefahr des scheiterns nicht
vorprogrammiert
doch natürlich muss ich sagen also man
schaltet natürlich dann immer irgendwo
es geht ja nur darum dass man recht gut
regie führen kann stress also diese
gespräche kenne ich natürlich dass und
wie macht man das
und eigentlich geht es darum dass man
schaut es dann kriegt alles irgendwie
hin man muss immer so schieben nicht
also souveränität ist auch was gespielt
hast in diesen berufen und es ist ja
auch nicht so dass ich alles
gleichzeitig gemacht habe sondern manche
sachen habe ich gemacht schon und
was vielleicht ein problem sich ich
interessiere mich oft für alles und das
geht manchmal zu lasten von von tiefer
dass das ist sicher so also wenn man
sich schnell ablenken lässt und schnell
aufmerksamkeit auf andere themen lenkt
dann kommt man vielleicht manchmal gar
nicht so tief wie man will oder wie man
sollte aber keiner etwas entstehen aus
diesem jahr ist ja genau wie bei also
ist die bei kellermann hat da laut also
kleine sachen wie die die lade dazu
spinnst ihn also hier irgendwie ein
bonbon books aus zitronenschale und dann
nadel und dann osterei und da in den
kirchen und hier noch eine nuss und
irgendwas wird daraus es gibt eine
erzählung und man merkt die dinge
spielen miteinander und bei mir ist es
eigentlich auch ein bisschen so dieser
verschiedenen themen also sowohl
alltagskultur populärkultur als auch im
grunde klassischer germanistische
thematiken die machen zusammen schon oft
sehen also die man kann viel über
fiktion lernen wenn man sich mit
künstlicher intelligenz beschäftigt zum
beispiel also das ist so und
text ein vorträgen zu erhellen jetzt
möchte ich mit ihnen noch über etwas
ganz wichtig ist von keller sprechen was
wir bis jetzt ausgelassen haben nämlich
den humor ja den witz welche art von
humor ist denn das kann man das
irgendwie einfachen und warum ist ihnen
das so wichtig also ich würde einige
wenige von humor als von komik sprechen
also humor ist ein bisschen warum hat
eine andere perspektive die komik gibt
es bei keller ja aus diesen prozessen
über die wir schon gesprochen haben
können sie vielleicht diese abgrenzung
im jahr erläutern zwischen also gut dass
also humor heißt er im grunde bezeichnen
der ein vermögen das wir haben was mit
uns herumtragen nicht zu empfinden
können etwas das wir im grunde eine
situation in ihrem missverhältnis
einschätzen und als belustigen empfinden
können komik wäre was anderes komik ist
das was wir inszenieren können ich und
was keller macht ist natürlich in seinen
werken er inszeniert oder eher für
konstellationen herbei die wir komisch
finden ja und also da wo wir lachen
darüber sagen dass humor es vielleicht
ist es aber gar nicht so humoresk
sondern vielleicht hat das viel mehr was
mit komik zu tun das ist bei keller wie
folgt eigentlich hier
ich habe vorhin schon gesagt also die
diese lernprozesse die leute zurücklegen
müssen auf ihrem wege zurück vom
scheitern
jemand der immer meint er sei schon war
es und ist noch nichts das kann man
komisch inszenieren denken sie an den
händler kirche novellen also ein
pennäler der so tut als ob er schon im
grunde große gelehrte wäre und dann zu
setzen schreibt wie man sieht man sieht
die dinge lagen nicht so einfach wie es
schien oder dann immer über sich
dahinter schreiben dass man den sieg am
benennt also eine eitelkeit diamanten
schritt weg macht und von außen schaut
natürlich lächerlich lächeln lächerlich
wirkt und in dem moment in dem solche
leute dann diese rolle ausfüllen müssen
und weiterspielen müssen bis natürlich
immer lustiger ja dann ist das eine
komik der herabsetzung eigentlich jeder
betrieben wird
ist aber immer auch gekoppelt muss man
sagen diese komikern schnell umschlagen
in etwas tragisches also wenn sie denn
da auf mein weg nehmen jemand der auch
die ganze zeit in der falschen zeit lebt
und das ding ist das naja er steht im
grunde gegen seine weltweite zeit ihr
schauen auf ihn drauf und können ihn
verlassen
der kriegt aber diesen lernprozess nicht
hin der krieg ist ein lernprozess nicht
hinter lernt nicht scheitern sondern da
scheitert im tod
also wer stirbt dann am schluss und dann
wird's tragisch ich damit die komik
tragik aber diese diskrepanzen zwischen
dem schein und dem seien die schreitet
keller natürlich ganz oft und immer
wieder aus und das ist natürlich schon
lustig von außen betrachten
keller geht ja was vertreter des
realismus ja kann ich die beiden dinge
zusammen und geben diese komik und
diesen realismus ist irgendwie humor
dieser blick auf die welt und dieses
lachen auch über sich selbst ist es die
einzige haltung die wir angemessene
haltung die wir gegenüber der realität
haben können oder wie es da genau die
verbindung zwischen montreal es ist
sicher eine angemessene haltung
gegenüber dem realismus ist das große
problem ja dass die großen texte die mit
dem realismus heute zuordnen oder die
großen autorinnen und autoren die wir da
zu ordnen dass die in der praxis
eigentlich alle das gegenteil von dem
machen was die theorie eigentlich
anordnet also ist die theorie des
realismus die relativ stark begrenzt was
wie geschildert werden soll und was
nicht vorkommen soll keine gespenster
keine wo lust kann begehrens machen die
alles immer noch und man kann das leben
umgekehrt vielleicht sagen
wahrscheinlich lernt man durch keller
über realismus mehr als wenn man ja das
ist zuordnet nämlich was ja
der realismus eigentlich also man sagen
kann was was zeichen realismus aus der
realismus als eine literarische strömung
ist ja etwas das im nachgang also nach
goethe nach hegel nach dem großen gott
des 19 jahrhunderts der geschichte nach
den weltgeist angst ans licht kommt und
das was man dann mit immer man das
zeitalter der epigonen genannt hat und
der realismus kann im grunde sagen wir
das liegt hinter uns wir kriegen das
nicht mehr
es ist ideal als große kriegen muss ich
mir dieses was was man da das sind das
sinnliche scheinen der idee nicht in der
kunst
das kriegen wir nicht mehr hin das ist
nicht mehr das was wir leisten können
vielleicht aber auch gar nicht leisten
sollen weil wenn wir nur immer darauf
schauen welche gegenstände eigentlich
ästhetisch wertvoll sind welche
geschildert werden dürfen wo in ordnung
unter form haben dann entgeht uns
vielleicht ganz vieles ja würde ich
sagen
und dieses abbrechen dass man sagt wir
lassen das mal außen vor
und jetzt gucken wir mal hildegard
keller hat im einspieler fundament auf
das kleiner auf diese abwälzen
die dann noch das unterholz und da ist
auch noch dinge und die sind vielleicht
ganz spannend und faszinierend und aus
denen gibt es vielleicht noch so etwas
wie sehen zu generieren ja aus dem kann
man vielleicht noch was machen
vielleicht nicht das ganz grosse aber
das ist im grunde was realismus machen
was macht keller sehr wohl und das wäre
die aufgabe der kunst der literatur nach
keller dass man da ich ihn schaut die
sozusagen der idealismus die klassik
nicht hingeschaut hat ja das unperfekte
das gewusst und das kleinliche diese
dinge sprechen machen diese dinge
sprechen lassen
das so dass dinge überall an allen ecken
hier am glas hängen geschichten aus
denen sich im grunde für uns ansehen
generieren lässt
und die kunst steht hat eigentlich die
aufgabe genau diese geschichten zu heben
und für uns dadurch die welt noch mal
neu sichtbar zu machen
das kann ich aber nicht wenn ich sage
ich muss bestimmte gegenstände darstelle
an denen ich mich dann in meiner
wahrnehmung orientieren mussten sondern
ich muss im grunde sagen das was neben
daran liegt das was übrig geblieben ist
das hat auch in werth das sind die
figuren bei keller und das sind
natürlich die gegenstände und auch die
kleinen geschichte das klingt mir also
ein bisschen nach adorno auch also die
kunden zulegen wie das das kleine das
ausgeschlossene was nicht ins system
passt anständige irgendwie wieder zu
sprechen
das könnte man mit adorno so lesen ich
glaube durchaus auch dass die kritische
theorie an gang an keller auch sehr gut
anschluss findet der keller ist es
gleichwohl natürlich erstmal nicht
politisch gemeint nicht aber es ist
natürlich die die kehre die er hat ist
schon auch eine anti ideologisch das ist
schon eine art ideologischer kehre dass
man sagt man darf man also auch in den
in den text darum grünen einrichten die
abkehr vom vom ideal der burmesische
vechta nicht immer nachzeichnen muss man
doch warum eigentlich
warum eigentlich vielleicht geht es um
das was daneben liegt ja und diese also
einerseits dass die kunst unseren blick
verändert aber keller war ja schon auch
gesellschaftskritisch politisch sehr
stark engagiert und wollte er auch die
verhältnisse ändern also mitte des 19
die schweiz gründung des bundesstaates
88 40 davor und danach
sie sagen immer wieder damals gab es so
etwas wie einen kulturkampf zwischen den
konservativen katholischen und den
liberalen progressiven wo stand da
keller ethisch wenn man die
konservativen aus dem stand keller in
zeiten des lebens eigentlich überall
fast einmal kann man sagen
also man muss ja wissen
die geburt des schriftstellers kellers
nach der rückkehr aus münchen 18 42 die
erfolgt einmal haben eine politisierung
nicht dann ist er weg und freilich rat
der macht dann politische lyrik man
kennt so dass jesuiten lied nicht
kontext frei fahren züge
sonderbundskrieg dann später natürlich
auch gerichtet gegen die konservative
regierung in zürich die nach dem putsch
839 see installiert hatte und da könnte
man sagen da waren noch ein radikaler
eigentlich da ist schon noch ganz klar
erkennbar
er hat ja schon mitgelaufen aber wie man
ja durch einmal dinge weiß sind die
zürcher ja nie bist noch co2 gekommen
sind sind auch der kantons könnte gleich
in die beiz also es ist schon sehr
gespielt also das muss man sagen und
dann also da kann man noch ganz
eindeutig den radikalen zu ordnen 848
als in dem moment in dem man dem
bundesstaat hat geht keller
ironischerweise gleich sofort wieder
nach deutschland also die jungen jahre
krieg der gar nicht mit da ist er sieben
jahre dann erst in heidelberg und da in
berlin und hatte dann zurückkommt da
wird es dann interessant weil da hat
sich natürlich in der schweiz schon und
in zürich speziell natürlich das system
etabliert also an freezers zugriff die
liberalen eigentlich regieren da man
könnte sagt der große unternehmen genau
im gotthard projekt war es gebe nicht
beteiligt war gut ab aber dann krebs
schweizer kreditanstalt genießen die eth
mitgehen
naja das und natürlich das
einem grund auf die swiss re könnte man
sagen gehört auch dazu aber was was man
sehen kann ist dass keller da oft
natürlich auf dass dante laufdistanz ist
und dann sehr kritisch ist also man
vermutet natürlich auf der seite der
opposition die gegen die liberalen steht
bei den demokraten
das eigentlich die liberalen eigensinnig
sind also die es gibt in einem
wahlaufruf den keller 1860 initiiert hat
den ausdruck die verschlossenheit der
grundsätze das heißt man traut
eigentlich den liberalen nicht über den
weg und man sagt also bald darum geht
gefährdet man den profit und die
wirtschaft sind im grunde verfassung und
konstitution eigentlich egal
das macht sich natürlich fest 18 49 60
am gebäude handle
das heißt konflikt mit frankreich napoli
und dem dritten wo es darum ging setzt
die schweiz eigentlich recht durch nicht
und besetzt server und riskiert
natürlich an militärischen frankreich
den mann sofort verloren hätte also das
war ganz klar oder beugt man sich nicht
und die liberalen haben sich
zurückgezogen hat dann gesagt nee also
neutralität haben wir ja und neutralität
verträgt sich nicht mit interventionen
im ausland ja und da sind die dann auf
die barrikaden gegangen
stempfle ist das vor allem gewesen ja
dann das problem was sich ein bisschen
dann zeigt ist dass die die kritik an
dem system esta ist immer so ein
bisschen
wir haben soll man sagen ich würde mal
sagen nur - aber es wird nicht richtig
in genau und konkrete missstand benannt
sondern es wird auch das angedeutet und
das klärt sich dann nämlich 862 wird er
dann keller staatsschreiber als wächst
im grunde die seite er wird dann einigt
profiteur und man könnte sagen ein
bediensteter des systems se
und dann beginnt der eigentlich diese
opposition zu der vorher gehört hatte
ganz radikal zu kritisieren
in der novelle das verlorene lachen über
die ich gesprochen habe
da geht es genau darum ist es geht nicht
darum was haben die zu kritisieren
sondern wie gehen die vor nämlich eben
mit verleumdung mit man zieht im grunde
ehrbare männer an die öffentlichkeit und
der stellt ihnen uneheliche kinder
und dann kommen diese ganzen man könnte
sagen shitstorm mobbing verfahren es
gibt dann eine frau die heißt dann im
internet welle das öl weit die
eigentlich diese gerüchte streut und
koordiniert und dann erscheinen anonyme
schriften usw
und dagegen das zeigt ja eigentlich auch
so dass entwürdigt letztendlich die
opposition und gibt viel mehr eigentlich
den leuten recht die im amt sind und die
da beschossen also er ist nicht extrem
apologetik gegenüber esche aber er
schützt natürlich das system dann schon
als echter dein tod ist weder apologet
nicht da das denkmal von escher da ist
er
der tote ist quasi ein muster das man
erreichen kann dass keine mehr
irgendwie war es waren sicherlich jahren
einen rollenkonflikt den er dann hat als
staatsschreiber irgendwie über diese
firma oder wie viele sind wo er
irgendwie vom momenten plötzlich zum
repräsentanten dieses systems reagiert
genau in der zeit
ich möchte mit ihm noch mal zurück gehen
nämlich auch 10 8 und wir können eines
bundesstaates oder weg geht sehr sie
gesagt haben nach heidelberg und da
passiert eine wende wenn die möglichkeit
wäre es auch genannt erhört nehmen
ludwig feuerbach den großen
religionsstifter in china also keller
kommt nach heidelberg 18 48 und dahin
feuerbach allerdings nicht im
offiziellen universitätsgebäuden weil
das haben sie ihm verboten hält
feuerbach seine vorlesung
vom wesen der religion und für keller
ist dass das geistige erlebnissen
prägende erlebnis gewesen in seinem
leben kann man sagen also haben sie kurz
feuerbachs position also die kritik die
feuerbach an an der religion ja übt ist
ein dass man sagt man man muss sie im
grunde als eine kultur anthropologisches
phänomen betrachten die religion
emittieren so auseinander also nicht
gott hat uns geschafft sondern ja wir
haben die götter im grunde geschaffen ja
es ist keine position eigentlich die so
ganz radikal also die sks keine
atheistische position könnte man sagen
sondern das ist eine die noch immer auf
den punkt zurück kommt das was die
religion in uns schafft nicht
das kann man noch irgendwie benennen das
ist was no - ist nicht dass man kann das
dann seele nennen zum beispiel es gibt
bei forbach auch noch solche reste für
keller ist es ja interessant dass er das
ganz anders nun mal so es betreibt das
graffiti versagt feuerbach übrigens nach
seiner auskunft ganz schlechter redner
also ganz schlechter vorträge feuerbach
bringt mir eigentlich folgen das bei ich
muss die welt ist eine republik schreibt
daniel baumgartner
die welt ist eine republik die braucht
keinen monat reichen also einen
persönlichen gott der über allem steht
nicht der willkürlich verfahren kann das
braucht es nicht dass dieser gedanke hat
mich befreit
ja was geht damit einher sagt er noch
die unsterblichkeit geht in kauf also
unsterblichkeit gibt es auch nicht mehr
und dann sagt und das ist eigentlich
wichtig davor hat der angeklagte
zumindest aus der negation lässt sich
das auslesen
und dann sagt man na ja was bleibt uns
eigentlich dann noch keller hat dann so
die vermutung alle meinen das wäre
anders viel profaner an graue aber ich
sage es ist alles viel glühender und
farbiger und tiefer jetzt nachdem ich im
grunde mit all dem schluss gemacht habe
weil jetzt bin ich ganz radikal die seit
ich ja also das heißt er sieht
diesseitigkeit der verzicht auf diesen
überbau und das haben wir die verbindung
wieder zu den anderen geschichten über
die wir vorher gesprochen haben
er ist der verzicht auf diesen auf den
theologischen überbau ermöglicht mir die
sicht auf die wirklichkeit und darauf
das leben nach dem tod dass sie
tatsächlich dann dann ist dass wir jetzt
sind was wir jetzt haben das einzige was
genau es gibt sogar noch eine radikalere
forderungen er sagt er glaubt daran dass
es in zukunft keinen künstler geben wird
der nicht ausschließlich sterblicher
mensch sein will will sein will ja dass
kunst kann in seiner vorstellung mit der
machen der tatsächlich auf
unsterblichkeit verzichtet und das nicht
als ein konzept ansieht dass der kunst
etwas nützt also etwas transzendente
sondern kunst kann nur der machen die
wirklich nur in der wirklichkeit
eigentlich zu hause ist und auch die
dinge schaut das ist ein ganz ganz
prägen das erlebnis für ihn gewesen und
hat eigentlich alles weitere was wir in
dem bereich weltanschauung und keller
schreiben können ja bedingt sind ja ich
meine schon ungeheuer ein
mentalitätswandel mehr was da was kanada
vollzieht aber die ganze zeit macht das
ja auch durch also ich meine
säkularisierung irgendwo ist
realisierung modernisierung
liberalisierung da passiert unglaublich
viel und es entsteht eine neue
politische kultur man hat davor
irgendwie so etwas wie feinde gehabt
jetzt sollte man politische gegner mit
denen man argumente erreichen muss mit
denen man zusammenarbeiten
die politik wie gut haben und die
menschen damals das eigentlich
verarbeiten können aufgenommen also die
den umbruch meinen also ja da
dazu ist er kellersberg da dass man
genau das studieren kann wenn er sich an
seiner zeit ab arbeitet sieht man das
sehr deutlich die ist bewiesen wir uns
beschreiben könnte die kellersberg zeigt
einig den weg eine einer ja eine nation
in eine demokratische gesellschaft nicht
den übergang und was man natürlich da
sieht ist es ist keineswegs so dass man
knopfdruck macht und jetzt haben wir
verfassungen
es waren bundesstaat und jetzt läuft's
halt einfach so sondern was bei keller
immer wieder aufscheint ist das was
vorher war also eine zeit die sich
heroisiert also fehlender sieben
aufrechten nicht die sieben aufrechten
die eigentlich krieger war mit mit
jesuiten jäger mit mit gewehren ja und
die söhne werden mit einer schreiber
aber die alten sind noch da was macht
man mit den jetzt und diese kräfte sind
auch immer noch da und die betrachten
haben immer noch eine vorstellung von
feinden ja und dieses im wahrsten sinn
des wortes polemische denken sieht
keller in diese nach derzeit einziger
wir auch einzigen sieht irrationalismus
aber glaube ja dass das nach einem
endlager das läuft alles mit dass
versinkt im man könnte sagen dass ticker
zu 1 und keller in seinen auch in sind
wieder nicht machen sagen schaut im
grunde so von oben drauf märkte bewegt
sich immer noch mal was und hier bewegt
sich noch mal war so bands um armut
sobald man verhältnisse hat es um armut
geht wo leute an die existenzgrenze
kommen zeigen sich bestimmte phänomene
immer wieder und dann brechen natürlich
solche harrow ist man wieder auf und
aberglaube bricht wieder auf aktuell
weil man denkt die ängste der
mittelschicht abstiegsängste heute
populismus autoritäre regime das die
liberale demokratie gar nicht so eine
selbstverständlichkeit ist und das würde
ich gefangen ist er das mit sicherheit
ich glaube was nicht funktioniert ist
dass man sagt keller ist das wegen
aktuell wie genau die probleme die er
hat und er beschreibt bei uns
wiedersehen aber als ein spiegel
das heißt keller kann im grunde
beschreiben wie die junge
eidgenossenschaft eigentlich
untergründig durch dynamik geprägt wird
die sie eigentlich auch nicht
ausschließen will aber nicht kann ja und
ihr könnt natürlich sagen die schweiz
2009 10 oder vielleicht überhaupt die
westeuropäischen oder die westlichen
demokratien 2029
da tauchen bestimmte dinge aus diesen
motiven wieder auf und die keller gerade
einwandern sieht mich und die kommen
dort wieder auf und insofern ist das
werk natürlich zur analyse der gegenwart
durchaus sehr hilfreich und noch einen
anderen aspekt möchte ich gegen schluss
der sendung aufgreifen nämlich dass die
demokratie wir haben das schon wissen
angetönt auch von seiten der ökonomie
die höhe getrieben werden kann oder
bedroht sein werden kann wir durch die
vorherrschaft des der ökonomie das kann
man daraus das geld ist das irgendwie
auch ein korrumpieren der kfd
gesellschaft oder auf dem charakter des
einzelnen haben kann und das zeigt
keller in verschiedenen werken aber auch
in seinem spätwerk dem roman martin
salander
sie möchten daraus uns kurz eine stelle
anhören
gelesen von hanspeter müller drossaart
sich im literaturclub zum verständnis
der stelle muss man sagen es geht darum
dass die beiden töchter von martin
salander unglücklich sind in ihrer ehe
hielt in ihrer liebe mit zwei zwillingen
die bei gericht zwillinge und die mutter
des arbeitens wenigen gespürt dass und
die dann zu frau haben da und möchte
wissen was denn da los ist das wissen
wollen so muss ich es ihnen sagen meine
töchter haben ihre heirat bereut
so sagte die arme frau weil ich mit
gedehnten laute höchst betroffen und
bleich geworden
sie füllte das schöne lebens gebäude
schwanken dass sie mit so viel sorge und
kunst ihren söhnen aufgerichtet was sie
sich vom schreck netto verholt fragte
sie mehr kleinlaut als trotzig was denn
die frauen groß ursache hätten die
heirat zu bereuen
ja das ist eben das verwunderliche dass
sich mit der zeit verlieren kann weil es
ertragen werden muss sie sagen von den
jungen herrn es sei nichts mit ihnen sie
haben keine seelen mit rotem kopf den
sie so stark schüttelte dass der hut
darauf mit einem blumenband zitterte der
müden beine vergessen sprang die frau
weiter licht aus ihrem sessel auf und
rief tödlich beleidigt keine seele meine
zwei buben rund und nett hab ich sie zur
welt gebracht und jeden habe ich seinen
seelchen mitgegeben von meiner eigenen
unsterblichen seele wo soll sie dann hin
gekommen seien würden sie landschreiber
geworden seien keine seelen die
verfluchten gänze in diesem moment
erscheint ihr vater ihr mann in völlig
desolaten zustand jakob bekommst du
hierher als sie die ratlose verfassung
seine gesichtszüge genauer sagt
durchfuhr sie einen schrecken was
gegeben jakob fragte sie mit bleich
erforscht da das unbekannte welches den
sonst so ruhigen mann aus einem hause
getrieben
ihr doppelt schreckhaft erschien unser
sohn isidor ist in der stadt
er sitzt gefangen in schwere
untersuchung
sie haben ihn gestern abend gebracht
ja die beiden zwillinge die hätten keine
seele ja sie haben keine seele
man kann sich ja fragen haben die keine
seele weil die zwillinge sind oder sind
das zwillinge weil sie keine seele haben
in diesem text und ich würde sagen das
letzte ist eigentlich richtig dazu muss
man wissen dass sie nicht umsonst
zwillinge in diesem werk nichts gegen
zwillinge übrigens dieses zuschauen
sondern zwillinge haben ein problem in
kellersberg nämlich man weiß nicht was
ist das original und was ist das
duplikat ja das und das ist das könnte
für zwei menschen egal sein
das problem ist aber dass ich das auf
ein komplex bezieht der mit dem
wirtschaften zusammenhängen thorsten
produktion massenproduktion aber vor
allem etwas anderes nämlich wenn man
genau schaut die waidelich zwillinge
sind notare zwei notare
was machen die die haben schulden weil
sie sich verspekulieren die ganze zeit
und versuchen im grunde ihre schulden
damit zu begleichen
dass sie schulden verdoppelt also die
haben schon briefe die abgelöst werden
und die lösen sie aber nicht ab sondern
die kann man weiter verkaufen ja schon
wie man das bei uns von den 2008 von der
finanzkrise kennt also verkauft schulden
immer immer immer weiter und wünschte
sich michael als blasen und auf einmal
sammeln da muss einer zahlen und kannst
nicht und dann bricht zusammen und
keller untersucht eigentlich in diesem
roman genau dieses prinzip sagt also was
passiert eigentlich in dem moment in dem
ihr nicht mehr ganz einfaches verhältnis
haben jetzt die wahl war da ist im
grunde der betrag der einander der damit
der daran gefesselt ist also nun fest
ökonomie sondern mehr auf einmal geld
mit geld machen nicht wenn es
finanzautonomie gibt das ist für das
neunzehnte jahrhundert überhaupt ein
großes problem weil wenn man us stellen
zum beispiel ist
können sie nachlesen dass die
finanzautonomie natürlich buch hat da in
dieser zeit also es gibt börsenberater
und alles ne und büchern man machen kann
alle spekulieren das ist wie glücksspiel
während die wirtschaftswissenschaften
also die nationalökonomie
die halten das überhaupt gar nicht für
ökonomie die sagen finanzökonomie das
ist eigentlich nur spieler reid hat er
mit volkswirtschaft gar nichts zu tun
und man hat also gar keine begriffe und
gar kein verständnis dafür was da
eigentlich gerade passiert und was
keller macht ist dass er zeigt dieses
prinzip dass er sich wehrte auch werte
beziehen und hochschaukeln und leute auf
einen bankrott gehen weiß aber gar nicht
was ist passiert die haben doch noch
anders
wenn ich aber auf einmal haben sie
schulden oder martin salander selber
nicht ist irgendwie jahre lang in
brasilien und wirtschafts kein vermögen
gibt das an der bank die mit einem
zürcher bankhaus in kontakt steht kommt
zurück und da ist das bankhaus halt
bankrott und gar nicht hat er mehr nicht
das versteht man natürlich erstmal nicht
und ja dieses abstrakte gehört dass ich
selbstständig marx würde sagen rainer
tauschwert gebraucht werde ich meine
marx ist auch ein stichwort weil 1848
kommunistisches manifest diese idee des
kommunismus geistert darum bei keller
findet man immer wieder ein kapitalismus
kritische erstellen eben an diesem
casino kapitalismus schmecken konnte er
auch nichts mit dem kommunismus oder ja
also derart in den 80ern ganz fröhlich
hatte er durchaus kontakt das gab es ja
nicht einen kommunistischen bekannten da
war aber eigentlich nie richtig
engagiert muss man sagen nicht also dass
also das war keiner da war keine
parteigänger schafft eigentlich für ihn
zu suchen
die kapitalismuskritik kommt aber
natürlich schon daher dass man sagt es
es gibt so etwas wie im kapitalismus
eine dynamik die zum zu der substantia
lisi hrung von gesellschaften für kern
und kleidung entkernung und die
zwillinge sind eigentlich nur ein
symptom davon nicht erscheinen so weil
sie genau das tun was sie sind ja die
verdoppeln schulden
man weiß nicht mehr geht diese schulden
noch oder gibt die eben nicht mehr gibt
es die zwei mal aber sicher doppelt das
ganze tatsächlich sind sie aber nur der
ausdruck einer ganzen gesellschaft da
martin salander selber nämlich ja der
investiert auch in immobilien von denen
er gar nicht weiß wo die stehen also er
geht durch eine straße der irgendwo habe
ich hier auch investiert glaubt noch an
dieses an dieses prinzip und ist dann
hat mir ganz ganz schlecht kenntnis
dieser welt menschen kennen ist der kann
überhaupt nicht unterscheiden was ist
ein wert um was ist keine seine frau
kann dass ich selbst kann das nicht
er selbst geht auch so über
wirtschaftssystem sein eigenes das über
sklaverei funktioniert hinweg die frau
spricht an
es gibt also ganz viele verwerfungen
habe die kapitalistische verwerfung die
keller sieht und auch benennt durch die
frauen durch die frauen die frauen
können das sagt welche rolle spielen
denn die fragen in seinem werk ja enorm
große also abgesehen davon dass
natürlich auch einige der witzigsten
oder ja man könnte sagen kann
charismatischen figuren frauen sind die
prinzen habe ich schon genannt aber es
ist so dass die frauen in der regel die
sind die auch ordnung schaffen können
und die im grunde diese illusionen die
sich männer machen
am schnellsten brechen können ja wm
sagen können das bist du nicht
und die die auch erziehen können ja also
und frauen sind eigentlich bei keller
und zu einem teil natürlich diese
katalysatoren also die können
tatsächlich so dass ware vom falschen
könnte man sagen scheiden ja man kann
natürlich sagen inwiefern sind frauen
hier figur auch wirklich mit entwickeln
nicht inwieweit gibt es nicht auch
wieder diese stereotype die die
literatur des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
immer wieder durchziehen nicht also die
idee die diese heiligenfiguren ja die
unberührbaren nicht die die man könnte
sagen die die kins frauen andy rain ist
was den ich es ja genauso metal ein dass
die hamas eine figur die ich sehr sehr
interessant ist aber den grünen einen
grünen heinrich ja ein bisschen gegen
gegen ende der sendung würde mich noch
interessieren dass wir haben jetzt über
verschiedene aspekte gesprochen aus
schriftsteller des scheiterns könnt ihr
sagen vereinfacht aber auch aus
gesellschaftspolitischer
gesellschaftskritischer autor
sie leiten ja auch ein blog geschichte
einer zurückzugeben was ihre digitalen
almanach ja digital nach genau das heißt
sie beschäftigen sich auch stark mit dem
was derzeit jetzt publiziert wird wie
aktuell und mich würde interessieren
welche autorin welcher autor wäre denn
der gottfried keller
man weiß nicht ob man den leuten damit
einen gefallen tut aber ich würde sagen
wenn wir uns also bestimmten aspekten
orientieren
zum beispiel so was wie judith
schalansky verzeichnis einiger verluste
das ist ein text der genau das macht was
keller auch macht die aufmerksamkeit auf
dinge richten die eigentlich schon
verschwunden sind ja die es nicht mehr
gibt die verlust gegangen sind und aus
diesem nichts aus diesen fragmenten die
man noch hat ja im grunde von sap wo zum
beispiel nicht kultur geschichten
schreiben große kultur geschichten
schreiben die atlas macht so was wie der
atlas der abgelegenen inseln
also man weiß genau was kommt da nie hin
aber daraus kann man geschichten machen
das ist jemand der im grunde so eine
bestimmte technik die keller hat weiter
führt in in unserem sinne übrigen auch
jemand der natürlich vielleicht nicht
von ungefähr grafisch als als das buch
designerin tätig ist also wie keller
auch diese grafische aber noch hat wer
auch nur eine anbindung judith
schalansky deutsche autorin ja und genau
dieses verschwinden oder dieses
vergängliche ist ja auch wieder mit dem
scheitern so bunt nach mit ihr
diesseitigkeit die wir besprochen haben
vielleicht ganz zum schluss noch ein
lesetipp von ihnen wenn man mit keller
einsteigen möchte oder alles schon
wieder vergessen hat von der schule also
ganz spontan würde ich sagen die leute
von sila leute von ziviler sind haben
eine relativ geringe schwelle zum lesen
nicht nur gewicht vom gewicht her
vergleichsweise kürzere novellen ja man
kann auch pausen dazwischen machen
es ist aber natürlich so wie das auch
peter format immer gesagt hat das
gemeine an keller ist eigentlich anhalt
man kann ganz leicht reinkommen man kann
ganz leicht einsteigen bei meyer zum
beispiel ist das viel schwieriger aber
man glaubt dann immer dass wir als und
leichter auto das ist ja gar nicht also
man kann es auch fünf mal lesen und dann
findet man immer noch viele sein
aber ich würde mit wiederbeginn das ist
auch so ein bisschen das heißeste was
man hat ja unseren vier und herzlichen
dank das gespräch ich danke fürs hier
sagt ja bald schon sind europawahlen und
auch angesichts der turbulenzen um den
dreck sitz dürfte es spannend werden
barbara bleisch diskutiert nächste woche
mit den politikwissenschaftlern ulrike
gero und frank schimmelpfennig über die
idee europa und fragt ist europa mehr
als ein kontinent und jetzt gleich
gibt's musik und zwar zum abtanzen und
die klingt so
[Applaus]
ja und wenn sie wissen wollen warum das
duo daft punk musikgeschichte
geschrieben hat dann bleiben sie dran
[Musik]